okay who is this
steven zerk no
oh this is dimitri oh i'm playing my
former coach
i didn't know dimitri plays title
tuesday
good luck to dimitri he played chicago
open blitz
this is my long time coach from uh
the point i was like 1600 through
[Music]
like 2400.
and these are basically the reason why i
became
like expert and then master and then i
am
uh e3 i'll take
there's some 984 move
what's the line here
you can take your first
we've played a few times in otb play
uh one of the first times we played we
drew in like 12 moves cause he didn't
want to play me
has the padawan becomes the master
bishop b7
[Music]
i want to explain the h2 pawn but
not so easy
[Music]
i think the plan here is to like play
queen c7 c794
even 94 right away
i do have f5 maybe
that's tricky
a5
i want to time it so like roxy when i
taken oh my gosh
i just blundered i just plundered a fork
oh okay
i was about to blunder a queen too
that'd be so
tragic
let's not tilt
maybe
let's move first
it's actually still a game
got some center control
i'm not proud of what i just did there
though
queen should come back
okay i have a fork in the position
knight t2
but does it do anything
i can't i couldn't play it right away
and there's even like queenie one ideas
queenie one
i think it makes sense to trade the
bishops
a3 is a bit tender
this bishop is kind of sad
f3 is a good move though
and if i take
oh there's a crazy line
it doesn't work the bishop d4
[Music]
have to play this
i will reroute
if i take
27
kh1 is probably coming
yeah dimitri has like a very uh
karpovian type style
i mean the hope is rook f6 takes and
not happening though
so king g2 there's knight f4
adding this now
not even a threat rook c8
oh no my bishop
chuck
i'm still completely lost
that's a sad thing
but there's hope at least
[Music]
okay
oh man
uh probably didn't deserve to win that
game but things got messy in the time
scramble
and
yeah i assume that f4 is missed
um
it should still be winning for light
though
but this
this is probably
not the best thing to blunder like i
should be a very very much aware of
what's attacked
after every move
wonder if eric's heart rate is directly
correlated to the number of dirty
halvard comments
yeah in combination with like blundering
simple forks
i just got outplayed i think from the
opening
um
because this like these things are
clear targets
although maybe it's still interesting
like i should play rook f6 and then just
go for the attack
very stonewall like
but dimitri is a reason why
like
he was responsible for teaching me
positional chess
learned
learned from a lot of
karpov games that he fed me